تجاوزت حصيله قتل زلزال سوريا وتركيا 37
الف قتيل غير مئات الالاف من الجرحى
وملايين المتضررين ومئات الاف البيوت اللي
تدمرت واللي مهدده بالانهيار وعلى الرغم
من مرور اكثر من اسبوع على حدوثه لا زالت
الهزات الارتداديه مستمره والزلازل بتضرب
المنطقه بين حين واخر ورغم انه هذا
الزلزال تارك في قلوبنا ونفوسنا اثر لا
يمكن للمحي يعني بيوم وليله ومثل ما حفر
كمان حتى بذاكرتنا مقاسي وقصص مؤلمه لسه
في لحظات حقيقه يعني معرفه اوصفها الا ان
بانه يعني فعليا معجزه ولسه في نجاسه
بتطلع من تحت الانقاض عايشه حتى بعد مرور
اكثر من 200 ساعه على الزلزال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن بين فيديوهات لحظات الانقاذ في فيديو
خطف القلوب وهو للحظه الاولى لاخراج طفله
سوريه من تحت الانقاض واللي اول ما جات
عينها في عيون منقذيها هذا اللي قالته
كده
[موسيقى]
في فيديو اخر وكمان للطفل سوري ومتداول
بشكل واسع الساعات الماضيه وحقيقه من اكثر
المقاطع المؤثره وبيوثق لحظه شمل لم شمل
طفله سوريه تم انقاذها بوالدها اللي نجح
هو كمان وما بيجي غيرهم الاثنين من العالم
[موسيقى]
والله
[تصفيق]
عسل
[موسيقى]